bonne nouvelle pour les clés siens jeudi
dernier le conseil municipal a voté une
baisse des impôts de 3 %
un manque à gagner estimé à 500 mille
euros rendue possible grâce au
développement des zones commerciales sur
la ville c'est le maintien même
l'accroissement de bulles alpha parc de
plus d'autres zones qui se sont créés en
phase d'alpha park 2 et sa n'intègre pas
les futurs centres commerciaux comme
moine les chemins l'ouverture des
nouvelles enseignes alpha park 2 a
engrangé 1 millions de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires à elle seule pour
l'opposition cette rentrée d'argent
aurait pu être utilisé différemment
il y à des travaux d'entretien à faire
notamment la voirie avec les hivers
rigoureux qui se sont succédé la voirie
qui est un patrimoine coûteux à
entretenir aurait pu comment dire faire
l'objet d'investissements nouveaux et
cet argent aurait pu servir à ça même si
on se peut se féliciter que les impôts
baissent ce que je crains c'est que ce
ne soit qu'une année
sous-entendu uniquement pour cette année
clé précédent les municipales la mairie
des clayes-sous-bois s'en défend et
compte sur le développement de one
nation ainsi que sur un tout nouveau
projet hôpital ou proches de ces
terrains aux abords de la foire et pour
continuer à grossir leurs recettes et on
a une grosse zone de développement
économique qui serait réalisable sur sur
cette zone qui est long de la rn12 avec
l'hôtellerie des services peut-être des
bureaux des commerces avec surtout vu la
situation de la zone donc l'aspect
environnemental extrêmement élaboré avec
des activités qui pourraient être
tournées vers la nature vers la remise
en forme
tout n'est pas encore finalisé la
préfecture a demandé notamment des
améliorations en termes d'évacuation des
eaux
avec ce projet la mairie espère créer
des liens avec la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et être prête
pour la ryder cup
ils représenteraient de 1600 à 1800
emplois